netania cuchillo netania juno Parece ser
otra vez en la incógnita para los 6,2
millones de votantes habilitados en
Israel en estas elecciones las Quintas
en menos de cuatro años el posible
regreso del este Primer Ministro que
enfrenta un juicio por tres cargos de
corrupción va de la mano del ascenso de
la extrema derecha representada en el
ilusionismo religioso una alianza
composiciones racistas anti Árabes y
homófobas que tiene su base de votantes
entre los colonos aquellos que apoyan la
elección total de los territorios
palestinos ocupados y los judíos
provenientes de medio oriente y el norte
de África enfrente está el fallido
gobierno del cambio la coalición
liderada por el actual Primer Ministro
interino Yair lapid que enfrenta una
paradoja por un lado su partido y ella
teeth crece en la intención de Voto pero
es a Costa de algunos de sus socios de
coalición principalmente la izquierda en
los partidos laboristas y merex que
podrían enfrentarse a su peor resultado
histórico esta voz de comicios son
declarados un día nacional de Israel Así
que tanta gente salga a la calle pero
hay que ver cuántas efectivamente va a
las urnas y la participación será un
aspecto clave principalmente entre La
minoría árabe que representa un 17% del
padrón al margen de lo político de
aspecto económico es la principal
preocupación un 44% de los israelíes
dijo que definiría su voto en función de
este aspecto y sobre todo teniendo en
cuenta el alto costo de vida que sitúa
Israel como El séptimo país más caro del
mundo y el segundo mercado inmobiliario
más caro del mundo lejos en la agenda
quedan aspectos como la violencia en si
Jordania ocupada que ha llevado al año
más mortífero para los palestinos desde
2015 Si todos estos ninguno de estos
elementos logra romper el estancamiento
político Israel se encaminará a sus
sextas elecciones que se realizarían en
mayo próximo